[Music]
this morning on the dish the man known
as the bread whisperer chef Chad
Robertson's culinary journey has taken
him across both the Atlantic and Pacific
Oceans he graduated from The Culinary
Institute of America and met his future
wife and business partner Elizabeth
along the way the couple worked and
trained throughout France and then
returned to the US where they opened San
Francisco's popular Tartine bakery and
just last month Tartine opened its first
overseas flagship with a location in
South Korea and another bakery in the
works for Los Angeles chef Chad
Robertson good morning welcome to the
dish thank you pleasure to be here we've
got a spectacular table tell us what's
here well yeah we haven't quite an
assortment this is ricotta and cornmeal
upside-down cake with a winter citrus on
top you kind of have a theme with a lot
of these things in the dishes we have a
little gem salad with shaved carrots and
also ricotta on the bottom with some
fresh herbs
porchetta and the center there mmm mmm
and over here shelling beans in broth
and then we have at our team which is
the toasted bread with also ricotta and
winter citrus amazing all right I don't
see West Texas in its table but that's
where you're from yeah so tell us a
little bit about how that shaped the man
yeah well so I grew up in West Texas and
you know pretty simple food for the most
part lots of good barbecue we all know
but my my mom and dad were both pretty
adventurous cooks in different ways so I
was definitely open to new ideas and
sort of enjoying seeing things that I
hadn't seen before your dad was actually
a punter for the New England Patriots it
was when you were a ranked tennis player
as a teenager I was yeah sports are a
big part of West Texas and all of Texas
but the interesting thing about my dad
is of course I had to play a sport but
he didn't really care what as long as
you know I really focused on something
so I tried everything and I settled on
tennis but it's not we're doing
professionally your grandfather was a
craftsman I read that that sort of
working with your hands was a big part
of the war of of cooking my grandfather
on my mother's side and
great-grandfather on the same side our
cowboy boots saddle makers super
traditional stuff and I kind of grew up
in the boot shop for a few years and
just seeing people work with their hands
you know it was definitely drawn to that
I didn't know what I wanted to do
exactly I wanted to travel so the idea
of learning how to cook sort of seemed
to hit both of those boxes where I could
travel anywhere
work with my hands and find work you
know anywhere in the world so at the
culinary institute you not only learned
about cooking but but from what I gather
alphabetical proximity is what
ultimately led you to your story your
wife yeah yeah that was a funny thing
because there were there were mostly
guys in the class and like maybe two or
three girls and and my lovely wife was
one of them and our names were together
in alphabetical order so we were put
together as partners mm-hmm so we
started as friends and then we started
dating and you know it's been 25 years
so then you've traveled the world
together learning baking techniques and
learning more about bread which is
really the showstopper at Tartine you
guys are using ancient grains why is
that important and what do they lend the
bread that other yeah so I took a trip
to Denmark and that was where the whole
idea of of ancient grains came from
because Klaus Meyer had been working on
this with the whole team of breeders and
and farmers for years and they they
brought all these ancient Nordic grains
back and and all the chefs in Denmark
were also this is six or seven years ago
still but doing really interesting
things and it just dawned on me that you
know as a baker I grew up with white
flour and whole wheat flour and that's
it you know and really you know dozens
of hundreds of different grains
now people reserve your bread in advance
that happens yeah we're making more
bread now for so long you know 15 years
we only had a certain capacity and now
that we have another spot we make more
bread but we still make a point of
baking throughout the day so you can
always get a hot loaf of bread if you
come to our team and you guys have
expanded to Korea world domination for a
Tartine curry has been fun yeah chef as
they ask you to sign this dish I will
ask you the question we ask everyone on
this part of the program if
you could share this meal with any
figure pastor present who would it be
you know honestly with all the travel
and all the work and all the expansion
when I'm thinking about who I want to
share a meal with right now it's it's
with my wife and my daughter because I
don't have enough of those right on
right on chef chef Chad Robertson thank
you and congratulations on all your
success and for more on Chad Robertson
and the dish head to our website at CBS
this morning dot-com